hi i'm michelle of vlad muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and cosmetic
chemist today i'm going to be reviewing
a bunch of korean skincare products i've
recently tried from brands i haven't
really reviewed much before and there's
actually some really interesting biology
involved this video is sponsored by
style korean an online store that stocks
a lot of korean products which i'm sure
no one expected from the name like and
subscribe and click the notification
bell so you know when new videos go up
the first brand i'm talking about is
lagom lagom means not too little not too
much just the right amount in swedish
and that's pretty much what this
skincare brand's approach is their
products try to give skin what it needs
in the right amount and removing what it
doesn't need but not removing too much
the main thing that made me really
interested in lagom is that the people
behind the brand includes a team of 12
scientists and dermatologists as well as
one of korea's top makeup artists which
is a combination you don't often see i
think it's really cool to get this broad
range of input from a lot of different
experts i think you end up with a much
more well-rounded product that way i
really love their branding and packaging
as well their scale logo is really cute
maybe i like it because it's pretty
similar to my website branding i've
tried a couple of lagon products before
i've reviewed them on my blog and i
really like the formulations but they
just didn't really fit into my routine
the cell up gel to water cleanser is a
really gentle morning cleanser but i
don't really need a morning cleanser
their sunscreen has a really nice
formulation but the uva protection was a
bit too low for me it's got pa with
three pluses and i just really need uva
protection so i was pretty excited to
try these formulations and i wasn't
disappointed the first one i'm going to
talk about is the cellus deep moisture
cream this is one of the nicest
moisturizers i've ever used i'm not sure
if i can save favorite yet but it is
definitely up there
it's really lightweight and hydrating
you don't need to use a lot it absorbs
really nicely it has a silky texture it
works really well under makeup which i
guess is not surprising given that a
makeup artist had input i'm actually
wearing it now i mixed it in with my
foundation it also works really well to
hydrate your skin overnight and it's one
of those moisturizers where your skin is
still hydrated in the morning and
surprisingly it was still hydrated after
washing with cleanser i have pretty
dehydration-prone skin so finding
something that gives me that dewyness
without being too much or too heavy
because i'm also oily is amazing this
cream gets my skin to that perfect
amount of dewyness where it's not gross
and shiny but it's just really hydrated
getting your skin well hydrated is a
really good way of hiding pores and
texture if you plump up your skin then
pores and fine lines look a lot less
obvious that's what you really want if
you're going for glowy skin you want
smoother texture and hydration is one of
those things that seems temporary but
makes a massive difference if your skin
is dehydration prone and you want
something that really packs a punch
without being too heavy or greasy this
is so good it is fragranced but it's not
too strong and the smell goes away
really quickly it smells a bit like
lemon lollies it has been clinically
tested to be really non-irritating so it
should be fine for sensitive skin unless
you're really unlucky in terms of
ingredients it's got lots of humectants
and light emollients and an active
called aquilecia aquilesia is listed as
hydrolyzed vegetable protein in the
ingredients list it's actually an acacia
seed extract mixed with maltodextrin and
this works on aquaporins you might have
heard skincare companies talking about
nobel prize winning science and
basically what this is is the nobel
prize in chemistry in 2003 was given to
two scientists that worked on
discovering channels in cell membranes
the cell membrane is like the outside of
a cell the barrier it's sort of like the
skin of a cell if we zoom in it looks
like this so for a substance to get into
a cell it can either diffuse through the
cell membrane which is quite tricky some
molecules can do it some molecules can't
and you can't really do much to help
that the other option is if it fits into
one of these special channels it has a
much easier time going in it's sort of
like a vip entrance there are tons of
different channels and one type is for
water and these are called aquaporins
because they're sort of like a special
pore for water now the top layer of your
skin the stratum corneum or what we
usually call the barrier this acts a lot
like a cell membrane much like a cell
membrane there are aquaporin channels in
it and it turns out a lot of ingredients
that interact with these aquaporins are
really effective at hydrating deep in
your skin for example one of my favorite
ingredients glycerin my precious is one
of the few molecules that some of these
channels let through along with water
and it's probably one of the reasons why
glycerin is just so darn good at a
hydrating skin it also turns out that
tons of ingredients that we already use
in our skincare products seem to do
stuff with aquaporins and some of them
aren't really well known for
moisturizing so for example caffeine and
retinoids are really good at acting on
aquaporins and we all know that
retinoids do not hydrate your skin so i
don't think it's really worth
specifically seeking out aquaporin
products if you want to help hydrate
your skin it doesn't really tell you
more about whether the product will
hydrate your skin than reading reviews
or trying it out on your skin this
ingredient has been specifically tested
for hydration and it works really well
it is also a humectant so it could also
be that long story short whether it's
the aquilecia or the rest of the
ingredients that's doing the work this
is an absolutely gorgeous moisturizer
that hydrates my skin so much better
than a lot of other products i've tried
so i think it's probably the combination
of both the next largon product i tried
was the cellus aquiline solution this is
an anti-aging and hydrating essence it's
a newer launch from lagom it's only been
out for less than six months and it is
very hydrating i would say it is kind of
violently hydrating it has a really
unusual texture that i quite like it's
very thin and it feels like an oil it
spreads really easily and after it's
been absorbed it's not oily it's
probably the product with the most
dewiness packed into each drop i've ever
tried on my whole face i needed like
four drops and i think it's actually a
really good value hydrating product
because you need so little to spread on
your face this has a lemon fragrance it
is a bit stronger than the cream but it
doesn't become too noticeable if you mix
it into another product and you don't
really need a lot of it as well as
aquilesia it's also got aquatide which
is a really interesting anti-aging
peptide it works on texture it
moisturizes skin it's also antioxidant
it's gotten tons of rewards and hype i
really like this it is excellent and
hydrating but i guess i'm not quite as
impressed by this as i am with the cream
because there are quite a lot of
hydrating serums out there although the
texture of this is really lovely and
quite unique and i think i'll be using
this a lot more going into winter the
next i tried is ato palm and i was
really excited to try these because atop
and their parent company neofarm they're
really famous for doing a bunch of
peer-reviewed studies on skin care
they're particularly well known for
studies on moisturizers and the impact
of moisturizing on your skin and on your
body in general if you read articles and
textbooks about the signs of
moisturizers you'll just keep coming
across at hopamaneofarm these products
are mle products and what that stands
for is multi-lamellar emulsion
technology what it means is that these
products use the right mix of three
types of lipids which are oily
ingredients specifically its
cholesterol-free fatty acids and
ceramides and they actually use pasted
versions that they make from plant
ingredients this mix is special because
it means that the final product has a
really similar structural arrangement to
the lipids that are naturally in your
skin barrier so the idea is these
products are really good at meshing with
and adding to your skin's lipids so it's
adding a barrier to your skin while
being as similar to your skin as
possible there's evidence that this is
better at hydrating skin and it makes a
really good base for delivering active
ingredients the research on mle has been
around for almost 20 years so it's
actually quite surreal to be holding and
using the products that i keep on
reading about so yeah i guess it's
pretty obvious that i'm probably pretty
biased here because i'm reviewing these
products after seeing scientists hype
them up ever since i started getting
into the signs of skin care i guess to
no one's surprise the atop has a really
good reputation as a derma cosmetic in
korea these are those products that
dermatologists recommend for sensitive
skin fun fact some of the researchers
that did the mle research including the
founder of atop were involved in
developing aquatide which was the active
ingredient in the largan product first
up we have the mla cream this was the
first korean skincare product to be
officially recognized by the ministry of
food and drug safety as
a functional cosmetic helpful in
restoring the skin barrier function it
has the ml in it which is the special
mix of ceramides and lipids it's also
got a whole bunch of other moisturizing
ingredients like shea butter hyaluronic
acid amino acids and allentown this is a
really thick cream with a mild
eucalyptus scent it feels sort of like
you're getting a really light whiff of a
medicated ointment it's targeted for dry
and sensitive skin so it's thicker and
more emollient than a lot of the other
products i've been trying
but it still doesn't feel greasy i have
oily skin and it's coming to the middle
of summer here in australia so i haven't
really been able to test this properly
on my face but i did have a flaky elbow
for a week that i just kept on ignoring
because that's just who i am eventually
i remembered i had a whole bunch of
skincare and i should do something about
it so i put this on it and it pretty
much just stopped being flaky overnight
which i thought was incredibly
impressive the mla lotion is pretty much
the same sort of product but it's in a
much more lightweight texture i've been
really impressed by the cream so far i'm
going to have to test it out properly in
winter and i'm going to have to try the
mle lotion on my face in winter but so
far everything looks really good the
final brand i tried is from neogen
dermalogy
it feels like i'm missing a syllable
there
dermaled
dermology
dermalogy neogen is a brand i've seen
around but i haven't really tried them
and there isn't that much info about the
brand online so i don't really have a
good idea of what the brand story is
they have some mysterious six core
technologies thing and they might have
some clean beauty in there which i think
they've rebranded as conscious the two
products i tried are snail products from
their sicker repair snail range snail
mucus is a classic korean skincare
ingredient and at least two og asian
skincare bloggers named their blogs
after this ingredient 50 shades of snail
and holy snails it's one of the few
gimmicky exotic asian skincare
ingredients that stuck around unlike
things like starfish extract and horse
oil which i'm pretty sure no one cares
about anymore i think that's decent
evidence for snail extract working for a
lot of people it's good for a bunch of
things brightening hydration and
smoothing obviously snail mucus is not
vegan but the snails don't get killed in
the process of harvesting newer
processes claim that snails aren't
harmed on the website in the product
descriptions for these two products
neogen actually says
using snail mucus extracted in a natural
way not in an abusive or harsh way in an
environment where snails can live
without stress from the outside
environment
so they really make a sound like the
snails are in a day spa i'm sure it's
not quite that nice but
i think it is a lot gentler than it used
to be so both products have a lot of
snail makers in them they also have
centella extract which you can probably
tell from the seeker repair name the
cream also has two percent niacinamide
both of these have really gooey textures
which is pretty typical for snail
products they're really hydrating and
lightweight and a little goes a long way
with these the gooey snail texture was
actually a deal breaker for me with the
snail cream i found it really hard to
get a small amount out of the jar it's
also a bit liquidy so with my
pathological lack of coordination it
feels like it's always about to spill
out of the jar i also just really didn't
like the scent of this product it has
this berry-ish cherry smell which i just
have a particular version to it's also
stronger than i like and so i couldn't
really ignore it this does seem to be
reasonably good for sensitive skin
though i've seen reviews saying that
they usually break out with snail
products but not with this the snail
essence is a lot more manageable since
it comes with a pump but it does have
that same scent i do really like the
packaging though it's pretty cute and
fun but i think i'm just not really the
target audience for this i think maybe
i'm just too old i think these products
will work really well for someone who
wants to try some snail products that
target uneven skin tone that are also
really good at hydrating skin so i hope
this was an interesting review let me
know if you've tried any of these
products before and what you thought
like and subscribe if you like science
based beauty content follow me on
instagram and tick tock and check out my
blog as well and i'll see you next time
for more beauty science